hi everyone i'm really excited to
welcome jeannie you here today because
her work on colonial era natural history
in the dutch east indies
promises to resonate with scholars
across yale who are interested in
southeast asia the environmental
humanities
human nature interactions science and
technology studies colonial history and
more jeannie you is a phd candidate in
history at princeton university and
currently a short-term fellow at the
john
carter brown library you can see from
the background of that library in the
background
she's trained in early modern and modern
history of island southeast asia and
works at the intersection of history of
science medicine religious studies and
the history of the book she's completing
her dissertation
mediating islands ambon across the ages
under the supervision of michael laffin
and keith wailu and she's also the
author of a very powerful article called
wars and wonders the inter-island
information networks of georg everhard
roomfias published in the british
journal for the history of science as
well as numerous fascinating and
well-written book reviews
please join me in welcoming genie you
for today's talk which is entitled paper
chains from fields to archives a view of
the information economy in 18th century
colonial indonesia
jeannie
thank you so much eric
and thank you to everyone who's
attending today and
the council on southeast asian studies
at yale and of course to chris mosaker
who
helped to organize this
um since the summer
today i'll be presenting on a small part
of
the fourth chapter from my dissertation
which explores how cross-cultural
exchange shaped european and indigenous
knowledge formations
about ambon's natural world from the
17th to the 20th century
and what i'll be presenting today takes
us back
to the 18th century
let me share
my so paper changed from fields to
archives a view of the local information
economy in 18th century colonial
indonesia
assam suleiman was not a man of quiet
disposition
or so the documents would have us
believe
solemn's voice captured in translation
came roaring across the pages of company
records copied again and again in the
18th century
the year was 1705
a clear day in the month of may the
beginning of the year's dry season
captain lieutenant de beverage who had
traveled to the northern province of
ambon for a council meeting had no idea
that what he was about to witness would
make any kind of impact on future dutch
east india company considerations
according to the beverage an uncommon
commotion marked what was supposed to be
a routine council meeting in one of the
island's most lucrative provinces
assam suleiman whose high status as
orangaya guaranteed him a seat at the
council had protested vociferously
against new company demands
the company was demanding that
administrators lower the production of
cloves on the island
this was partly in response to an
intractable problem wrangling the dutch
east india company's high government in
batavia
millions of pounds of stored clothes
were rotting
and administrators could neither sell
them for profit
nor leave them to decay in the human
spaces of the city's cramped warehouses
one of the ways to keep this problem at
bay at least momentarily
was to reduce the total number of fresh
cloves shipped from ambon where they
were mainly produced to batavia and java
the center of voc operations in the east
indies
solemn was flabbergasted in hearing a
demand so counterintuitive to company
expectations for the past century during
which time the island's people had
become economically dependent on the
company's commerce and clothes
the yambunis suleiman emphasized had
labored tirelessly for years to meet the
demands of the company despite their
quote suffering and neglect of their own
trees
but now the company wanted the very
opposite
exasperated solemn was to have exclaimed
are we not now poor enough
what is so hard about letting them know
of our condition
just let them load the ships with ropes
to strangle us
then we shall deal with more of these
clothes and then some
the island's administrators imputed some
significance to soliman's retort
on the last day of may 1705 the governor
of ambon a man named balthazar quiet
sent a letter marked secret to
administrators in batavia
in it
he described news he had heard from the
beverage who supposedly repeated
suleiman word for word in dutch
now it is impossible to know if this was
what suleiman had actually said at the
council meeting
if he was indeed protesting the decrease
in the production of clothes why would
he say then we shall deal with more of
these clothes and then some
while there is reason for doubt
quiet suited confidence in its fidelity
he mentioned that the beverage who
witnessed and related this incident
would soon testify to its veracity in
person by quote word of mouth
since he was already on a ship bound for
batavia
while this may sound somewhat dramatic
this was relatively speaking a minor
event in the history of emblem
however
it was an important it has a it has an
important bureaucratic afterlife in the
voc provincial archive in batavia
the contents of quiet's letter would be
extracted and copied in company reports
demonstrations resolutions and
considerations
this was in part a coincidence
but it also happened at a time when the
company was honing a complex system
of information collection and retrieval
through their active use of past
documents from provincial archives
just four years after the incident was
recorded
a man by the name of john von horn
a prominent administrator in batavia who
would soon become the voc's governor
general
extracted suleiman's retort from koyat's
letter in full
and included it in a signed
demonstration to the high government
this was only the beginning
a chain of paperwork would carry
soleiman's words deep into the recesses
of the company's provincial archive and
batavia
allowing them to resurface
intermittently throughout the century
van horn's lengthy demonstration would
be copied word for word into the book of
general resolutions for that year
this rendered the incident and the
quoted traces of solemn's words
retrievable and extractable through the
use of what would eventually be known as
the realia repertorium
a working index of select marginalia
from the high government's daily
resolutions
assam solemn's name would appear yet
again in the latter half of the 18th
century
in a 1775 report about cultivating
banda's native nutmeg trees in ambon
so 70 years after koyet related it in a
secret letter in 1705
solemn's words would be used in this
report but reinterpreted
under vastly different circumstances
since the 16th century
natural expeditions were one of the main
sources of european information
gathering in the east indies
expensive but valuable such expeditions
became a ubiquitous part of imperial
activities in the early modern period
producing a wealth of books descriptions
drawings and paintings about plants and
animals minerals and stones people and
their cultures
as many have argued they conveyed
information advantageous for global
commerce significant for scholarship and
useful for
empires in this respect the 18th century
was no different
marked as it was by voyage's global
dimensions the most famous of which were
newly sponsored expeditions for the
gathering of natural historical
as well as ethnographic
knowledge and specimens for trading for
scholarship
this presentation asks a slightly
different question
after a century or more of collecting in
the dutch east indies how was past
knowledge about the natural world
retrieved and how is it read as
information having present economic
value
pertinent to global commerce
while explorers and administrators
continued to undertake expeditions
others began to rely on their own
provincial archives
reinterpreting the past and their
present context of the 18th century to
create considerations pertinent to their
governance in the archipelago
there are three main questions i would
like to address today
inspired by this bureaucratic afterlife
of assam soleiman's words
first
what were the archival strategies of voc
clerks
who retrieved information from the past
in other words how did administrators
read to govern
second and more specifically
how did the acts of extraction of past
information from the archive affect
colonial governance
and third
how might the history of the vocs active
use of imperial archives at the site of
colonial governance
help us to understand their attempt to
sustain the political economy of the voc
during its rapid decline towards the end
of the 18th century
the answers to these questions are i
believe connected
and i'm going to demonstrate it in two
parts
first i'm going to show how voc clerks
marginalists and archivists created and
actively used a new system of
information retrieval in the 18th
century
a system which involved the use of a
massive working index
then i will address how
retrieved information from past
documents were integrated into new
reports
which influenced administrative
considerations about labor in particular
towards the end of the 18th century
a time when the company was completely
drowning in debt
no longer fruitfully invested in
inter-asian trade and crippled by
inter-imperial competition
voc scribes understood that being able
to retrieve information was just as
important as collecting them
the retrieval of information about a
specific thing from the company's vast
archive proved to be a formidable task
this was because the company's daily log
books and resolutions had been recorded
and preserved by date
chronology in short formed the
organizational backbone of the archive
and written information lived under the
shadow of concrete dates
in recognizing the need for a more
efficient system of information
retrieval
administrators in the 18th century began
to create an alphabetical index of
specific things and names like cloves
and letters nutmegs and quicksilver
over the course of the century they
compiled an overwhelming number of
peritextual materials about real things
and places from the company's
handwritten tones of general resolutions
as the company's collecting activities
continued and papers accumulated
these indexes became a valuable tool
a guide for reaching back not just into
any past but the past of material things
the first page of these handwritten
indexes still preserved in jakarta
for the title general register of the
order of the alphabet in the order of
the alphabet
which in the 19th century was printed as
one master index of three volumes in
leiden titled realia repertorium
in organizing a system of information
retrieval by way of an index
clerks were beholden to the extent
marginalia that summarized a much
lengthier passages in the body of the
resolutions
since each indexed item of marginalia
was accompanied by a specific date
a clerk could have easily found the full
resolution
by looking up the pertinent day in the
book of general resolutions for that
year
towards the end of the 18th century
most certainly in the years 1789 and
1790
a group of clerks in batavia created a
collection of extracted passages
from resolutions dated between 1703 and
1719
the collection concerned one matter in
particular
the prodigious rot of millions of pounds
of cloves in batavia's warehouses
which was partly why asan suleiman was
asked to lower the production of cloves
in emblem back in 1705.
behind this history of how early 18th
century administrators manage the city's
vast amount of decaying waste
lies a history of how late 18th century
voc clerks were able to retrieve that
information from an equally vast amount
of paper
in this case one can actually retrace
how clerks retrieve pass information
from the index in its list of dated
marginalia for clothes
to original accounts from the company's
annual book of general resolutions out
of which they created selected extracts
the clerk's names
signed on every document they copied or
checked were the only clues to the time
of its collection
in other words the date of the retrieval
is not mentioned in these papers only
the date pertaining to the index
marginalia is noted
here's an example
in the first two folios of the bundle i
have been working with here on the left
side of the slide
one finds a list of succinct
descriptions
all numbered dated checked off and all
having to do with how the company
attempted to reduce the presence of
rotting clothes in the city
upon closer inspection it is clear that
these descriptions are marginalia
selected from the index
and are at least similar to if not an
exact copy of the margin idea found in
the corresponding pages of the general
resolutions
i'll take the first marginalia to show
exactly what the clerk would have had to
do with it
in 1789 a clerk by the name of leonard
duryguzzi must have spent some time
thumbing through the book of general
resolutions from 1703.
gutsy was one of 300 clerks working for
the company that year and his name was
included in the annual name book of the
company's sworn servants
having received instructions to extract
the resolution pertaining to the index
marginalia
theory gutsy would have first scanned
the top of the first 70 pages of the
resolution's table of contents
before finding the page numbers for the
year 1703
upon finding the month of june at the
top of the page he would have scanned
its left margin for the specific date
and upon arriving at the 15th he would
have seen a brief list of marginalia
about the day's proceedings
if he had bothered to peruse these at
all he might have learned that on june
15 1703 batavian administrators have
discussed the shipments of sun-kissed
silver and gold brought into batavia
from bengal in the coromandel coast
he might have also noticed that on the
same distant day a ship loaded with
animals sailed for the city of palembang
located on sumatra's east coast
for the express purpose of hauling
pepper
he would have also seen that twenty five
thousand pounds of white pepper were
loaded in a vessel bound for holland
but as interesting as these snippets
might have been duryguzzi was solely
charged with finding an entry to the
marginalia about clothes
more specifically he was looking for
some clue as to how quote the mixing of
moist and dry clothes have been found to
be detrimental for this for batavia's
climate
to be sure diriguzi found that
administrators in batavia faced a
problem with the cloves that had been
stored in the city's warehouses
they had discussed this matter in
relation to the ongoing exports of tree
bark that were to be contrasted with the
demand for spices from the western
sphere of the east indies where persian
and gujarati ships remained active
having inspected the warehouse stocks
administrators offered a reflection as
to quote the concept of mixing the moist
with the dry clothes
deciding that would be best to separate
them
given the local climate in batavia
moreover presuming that the dry ones
remained of quality these were to be
shipped separately for sale
three gutsy copied this passage from the
resolutions
his own copy and extract was then
approved and signed by the head clerk
philippa state l wike
like other company clerks working under
el
under the like
deri guzi signed his name on the bottom
left corner of the document ornately
curling the first and last letters but
abbreviating his first name as what as
was common practice
now suffice it to say that these clerks
eventually found that between 1703 and
1719
administrators in batavia tested various
labor-intensive methods to rid the city
of rotting clothes
first forcing a group of people referred
in some parts as arbiters workers and in
other parts of slava or
slaves
to stuff millions of pounds of rotting
cloves under the city's bulwarks
to ultimately removing them years later
forcing the same group of people to ship
them to nearby islands and dumping them
in huge man-made holes
nine feet underground
this process took around two decades
in the process of creating extracts
clerks actively decided on which
passages to include from the body of the
resolutions
which always had more information
more details of methods and accountings
of figures than were ultimately included
the extracts would lead to copies of
more selective fragments which would
then be weaved into other company
reports
one genre of which was called the
consideration
the consideration was one of many
administrative genres which exuberantly
referenced the papered past
replete with fragments of extracts of
past resolutions using the index
as well as past letters contemporary
field reports and handwritten extracts
of printed books
and it did so in order to argue for new
regulations
as i will show 17th century expertise
would be invoked
particularly when discussing matters of
the natural world that stakes for
imperial commerce
and the necessary labor required to
carry out the production of spices in
the context
of local colonial governance
in december 22nd 1775
batavian administrators william bretton
and hendrick falcons
signed their names on the last page of a
completed consideration
they had drafted it over the course of
one month
since having received rainier the
cleric's november field report regarding
the present state of ambon
the chain of these administrative
reports concerned a problem that had a
fraught if not an obscure past
the cultivation of nutmeg trees outside
of their native panda islands
the clerk revealed that in his report
that in fact this was not the first time
the company had felt the need to
experiment with nutmeg cultivation on
foreign soil
using past letters and resolutions he
revealed that back in 1695
when a series of devastating earthquakes
disrupted nutmeg and mace production in
banda
the high government had inquired about
sustaining their production elsewhere a
question of enormous consequence
considering the company's century-long
efforts to monopolize these very spices
in the banda islands for global commerce
ultimately after much back and forth
they settled for the island of ambon
reasoning that the ambonese people were
more experienced in matters of plant
cultivation particularly of cloves
in 1775
breton and falcons would learn from this
turn of the century experiment of nutmeg
transplantation
the specialized knowledge of preparing
nutmegs and mace from raw fruit parts to
commercially valuable spices was not so
easily transferable not even among
people from the same subset of islands
in the same region
this short-lived but exhaustive
experiment turned out to be a failure
by using the clerk's field report along
with extracts from books treatises
correspondences demonstrations and
resolutions
bretton and falcons would learn from
this history and come to make their own
judgments on how best to execute this
delicate operation in their present
what did they learn from
extracts of 17th century ethnographic
and natural historical writings was this
nutmegs ripened twice a year in bunda
their rightness revealed itself
through the natural splitting of the
nuts wooden shell
which revealed the mace so quote clear
red against a cool black
of the nuts outer layers
in the morning the enslaved people of
the island's local overseers
who had direct relations with the voc
would make their way up the mountain to
the high altitudes where trees
flourished in the mineral-rich soil
surrounding the island's active
volcanoes
arriving at the forest they would spend
their mornings and afternoons plucking
looking up into the sky among the
branches of the nutmeg trees they would
have seen the red mace in the crack of
the hull
and these they knew were right for the
plucking
they also picked the overripe fruit
which had fallen to the ground
overnight
and would drop these into a separate
basket
they knew not to confuse the fleshly
plucked from the already fallen
as the two kinds were to be sold at
different prices
around five in the afternoon they walked
back down the mountain each carrying
heavily loaded baskets of the fruit
which had to be prepared into spices
this painstaking work involved cracking
unspooling
curing and drying the fruit a process
which took in total at least 12 weeks
the extracted passages detail how in the
evenings the enslaved sharpened their
knives to crack the hard thick outer
layer of the fruit completely open
the cracking proved to be a difficult
process
they had to apply just the right amount
of pressure to cut through the fruits
shell and flesh
but to leave the mesa nut intact
based on the extract this procedure was
considered dangerous
sometimes with a little too much
pressure the knife would slice all the
way through which not only left the nut
and mace and pieces but also quote did
away with a slave's finger or two
the enslaved also used their hands to
unspool the red mace from the nut
vein by vein
furthermore the 17th century method of
drying nutmegs required the use of
indigenous technologies
a complex infrastructure built solely
for applying varying degrees of heat
continuously for six weeks
then came the caulking process
the enslaved would mix salt water with a
type of caulk creating a special liquid
solution into wheat into which each
dried nutmeg would be dipped three times
the skills technologies and knowledge
needed to carry out this long and
delicate process
from the plucking and the cracking to
the unspooling drawing and the caulking
were exactly what rendered the
experiment of cultivating nutmegs
outside of bunda so quote rare and
difficult
as britain and falcons learned sitting
in batavia in 1775.
back in 1699 administrators considered
bringing to ambon a number of quote
bandanese overseers and a few slaves who
understood that work
the slaves they wrote would be able to
impart in time the knowledge of how to
handle the trees and fruit to the
indigenous ambonese people
but they complained
even after having given enough courses
and lessons
the ambunies seem to have lost the quote
will and diligence to carry out the work
they claim that compared to the slaves
from banda
the ambunies were quote too lazy proud
and useless
to understand the special treatment and
knowledge necessary for cultivating
nutmegs
such turn-of-the-century comparisons
between slaves from banda and laborers
in ambon
influenced breton and falcons in 1775
as they considered how best to gather
enough manpower for the task at hand
the two administrators however
were not entirely convinced that the
ambonese were simply lazy and useless
after all they argued it was the
ambonese who had been cultivating and
preparing clothes for the company for
more than a century
they were also unconvinced of the
impossibility of imparting the skills
and knowledge needed to cultivate and
prepare nutmegs in what they called the
bandanese way
while they accepted these impressions
and repeated them in their own report
they began to search for an explanation
and in their search they came across the
name assam suleiman
whose verbal retort against the company
back in may 1705
left its own paper trail in batavia's
provincial archive
in 1709 four years after the recorded
incident at the council meeting with
which i began this presentation
yuan von horn included an extract of the
secret letter from ambon in his own
demonstration
van horn's main purpose for writing in
1709 was to use solemn as an example of
what he deemed to be the declining
character of the ambonese
for which he blamed the company and its
focus on commerce
it was what he called the avarice
of company ministers which had tainted
the local people with greed
moreover because of this he continued it
would be difficult to force the ambonese
to do anything without offense or marked
commotion
to provide evidence
he cited zoliman's retort word for word
from the original letter
are we not now poor enough
what is so hard about letting them know
of our condition
just let them load the ships with ropes
to strangle us then we shall deal with
more of these clothes and then some
his demonstration would be copied in
full into the high government's general
resolutions for the year 1709
and through its insertion into the canon
of resolutions which clerks consulted
throughout the 18th century using the
index as i have previously discussed
it would come to resurface in bretnum
falcons's own report
in their search for the labor needed to
cultivate nutmegs and ambon
breton and falcons 2 came to focus on
the influence of commerce on the
character of the indigenous people
echoing van horn they claimed that the
ambunies had lacked quote european
yearning that is the particular ethic of
merchants whose sole goal was to make a
profit
such yearnings however were no longer
linked to notions of greed
but to the ideal of productivity
citing the resolution which included van
horn's reference to the secret letter
brethren falcons quoted solemn's retort
and recast this mediated information
from the past
in the 1775 report to suit the
principles of the market economy
they recommended that in order to
satisfy the ambonese as a workforce
administrators would have to instill
commercial incentives
the clerk had initially advised the
administrators to pay the ambonese quote
with the gift of money
one that would be quote calculated
according to the supply of the previous
five years
retinum falcons vehemently disagreed
they believed that calculations
based on the previous five years would
not be satisfactory
this hinged on another assumption
about how local people understood time
and motivation
as they as they claimed that quote the
indigenous c's in the present as much as
in the future
rather than paying them based on bundled
calculations from the past then they
recommended that the company pay them
based on a fixed amount per weight of
production
for the two administrators the
successful cultivation of nutmegs had
everything to do with instilling
economic motives
and that transferring knowledge hinged
on increasing local people's incentives
such on the ground considerations and
thinking about knowledge labor money and
incentives and controlling the labor
force in the 18th century
may perhaps explain why
at a time when there was an acute
shortage of voc coins
the company would begin to print paper
money not only in batavia but also in
ambon in both dutch and in malay towards
the end of the 18th century
the two administrators differed from
their predecessors in key ways
while they agreed the 17th century
methods of preparing the fruit into a
spice was a delicate operation of
extensive expertise and training
they disagreed about the impossibility
of transferring such knowledge
for them this was not a matter of
character but a matter of economic
motive
furthermore they were keenly aware of
the company's overwhelming reliance on
ambunee's labor for the success of their
project
this presentation has dipped into one or
two key moments to assess how the
emergence of an 18th century system of
information retrieval within batavia
allowed officials to reach into the past
in a manner unprecedented to devise
on-the-ground solutions for specific
problems
it is indeed an intensely local case
of paper chains from a provincial
archive in batavia but also of
individuals whose voices are
metaphorically chained to the papers
which would be replicated within the
system i outlined
it was this process of converting
natural historical and ethnographic
information into economically and
commercially valuable information
which would ultimately inform other
reports that made their way up the chain
from batavia to amsterdam
as administrators in the provinces as
well as the metropole deliberated on how
to revive past cultivation and
transplantation practices for their
present dilemmas
in effect these administrators became
producers and reproducers of information
that fed an ever-growing paper
bureaucracy
lending blast to a company which was by
the last half of the 18th century
drowning in debt and crippled by
inter-imperial wars across the indian
ocean
through this process information
contained within various administrative
writings came to have a
protracted lifespan
as they were recycled in extracts over
the course of the century
i hope this shows the power of
provincial archives for historical
actors whose own prognostications were
based on fragments of mediated
information from a different time thank
you
thank you so much genie
let's take a moment everyone
to reflect on this talk for a moment
while you come up with questions um
we'll start the q a
in
just a moment or so as people gather
their thoughts
that was a very rich and wonderful
presentation thank you very much
um to the guests here i will moderate
the q a um if you have a question please
use the hand raise function
or turn your video on and wave your hand
wildly and i'll probably see you that
way too
michael i see that you have
you turn your video on does that
indicate an interest in asking a
question
absolutely
um
uh thank you uh this fascinating talk um
you have published on room theist
who was who was one of the great
encyclopedic uh compilers of information
of of the 17th century
so so listening to talk i'm wondering
if if there's any evidence
that
uh that some of these voc
um bureaucrats and and uh and archivists
referenced
any of
either any of his methods
or his uh his reports to batavia
or in the the 18th century
his publications
because of course
on spice production
he was
for a time
probably the
the the world's expert for for that part
of the world
yeah thank you so much michael for the
question
um
i have indirect evidence
that
voc administrators in batavia were
using information which rumfius had
collected back in the 17th century
mainly through
um
their use of francois valentine's old
and new
east indies
and as we know valentine was intimately
connected to
room fies and
derived a lot of uh his own writings
about spices
from roomfuse's works
um
roomfuse's natural history his herbal
wasn't published until the middle of the
18th century
in holland
and so
and it wasn't the print itself wasn't as
famous until the 19th and 20th centuries
when it would recirculate back to the
islands um
to influence you know renewed
bioprospecting activities
in ambon
um but for the 18th century i don't have
direct
evidence of voc clerks and batavia using
room fuses works
um
they mainly cite valentine who at the
time is much more
much more famous for his printed
ethnography
um
but i wouldn't be surprised if they were
influenced by
not roomfuse's
natural histories but his
administrative papers
many of which he dictated and his scribe
wrote down and many of which had his
signature
um at the end of the document
um
so there was probably some influence
from roomfias but um
not so much
in the 18th century as i can see
mainly in the 19th and the 20th
centuries
um as well as the 17th century when he
was reporting
back to
batavia constantly
thank you
while people collect their thoughts um
i have a question um as as you were
giving your talk i couldn't help but
think to myself
that um you're one more um addition to
the paper chain in a sense right um
you're writing a dissertation
about um the way in which people are
referring to other
uh texts and the text appear and they
reappear right and in a sense they
reappear on your powerpoint here as well
and so i wondered if you could
tell us the difference
and why why does
this period matter and why does this
place matter um specifically so you know
if you're doing in some sense you could
argue that you're doing the same thing
but you are not in the same place and
time
and so
does the meaning change
of the process or is it a kind of
universal historical process that you're
you're hinting at but then takes on a
specific meaning in a particular place
and time
and so i'm wondering if you could then
reflect on how this is specific in a way
to the 18th century
and to dutch colonialism
you know in in this region
and
then how that differentiates it to being
a princeton a scholar writing about it
in the 21st century
now eric thank you so much for that
question yeah it's
it's strange to kind of take a step back
from the dissertation writing and
reflect on
the fact that
this kind of paper chain continues
up to the present day
um
and of course there are clear parallels
between the way that these voc clerks
and administrators governing an empire
um use the archive
to
to write about these islands not only
ethnographically but historically and
for policy and regulation purposes
um
i think you know i see this process
happening
in multiple ways and i'll i'll come back
to like how i think of my
my role in all of this
the latest um translator for example of
room fuses um
herbal
i
recently found out was also kind of
collaborating with the pharmaceutical
company in the us
right and so that like every kind of
mediating
process whether that's collecting
documenting
translating circulating similar
information in various versions
has these on the ground
in impacts that um
i hope to kind of go into into the
present day
um for the book
but um i think my role is
to kind of
focus on um
the history of mediation and its
influence
in order to make us a little more
as historians
self-reflexive about um
the craft we practice
and
how every kind of historical document
that we're reading is
buttressed by
all kinds of
mediating influences and elements of
uncertainty
so it's certainly been um humbling
but at the same time
i am very much aware that i i too
am repeating um
their words and
you know it's um
i guess it's just one way of um
exploring but also critiquing the way um
we narrate the past
so
thank you for it's very interesting
there's a lot to think about there um
there's a question i don't know if you
can see it in the chat can you see the
chat bit window from elizabeth osborne
i can read it out loud or elizabeth if
you would like to ask your question
your you can unmute and do so
okay i'll do it elizabeth i'll read it
to you and that way everyone can see it
um
it says my apologies if this was covered
at the beginning can you mention a bit
more on the practice of slavery and
banda any
sense of how many people enslaved and
from where and whether intergenerational
or time bound within the lifetime of an
enslaved person
yeah so i can go into it a little bit
though i don't really specialize on the
history of slavery and bunda there are
others particularly in the netherlands
who
who really
delve deeply into this
um there is some debate i think among
historians about you know
whether the practice of slavery in the
eastern archipelago is kind of
a unique case in asia where it's much
more um
reminiscent of
slavery in the atlantic world
or whether it's it's um
kind of part of the the
uh you know
much more kind of a household slavery
system which anthony reid writes about
um
i
i don't really have much of a sense of
which which might be correct
but um
you know after the bandhan massacre in
the early 17th century
um
the
local overseers were basically the dutch
who were brought in and
were
in charge of
bandani slaves but also
other slaves who were brought into banda
from all over the archipelago
um and
over time by the end of the 17th century
which my talk
um kind of touched on
um
the overseers are no longer identified
as european or dutch or even
people who have like
um
uh
you know
dutch blood they're they're much more
seen as bandanese at that point because
many of them many of them had married
locally
but the slaves are also
considered bandanese and sometimes they
are identified ethnically
as being from different parts of the
archipelago i mean it's a really
fascinating case of how
identification based on ethnicity and
based on the name of the island
kind of comes into being in this part of
the world where of course after the
massacre you have a great reduction of
of local people but by the end of the
century you have this repopulation
through force
um
so i'm not sure if that answers your
question but it is
i believe um
[Music]
i think it is a light you know lifetime
over the course of a person's lifetime
that there they serve as slaves but um i
would have to check that
thanks there's another question um
in the chat for someone with the tiano
reed has unstable wifi so it says you
mentioned at the beginning that you
weren't sure if the original quote was
spoken by suleiman or that you had
questions about its authenticity can you
say more and i'm wondering if he was
specifically being recited and held up
as some kind of quote unquote genuine or
authentic local voice
yeah i i um
had someone ask me this question
previously in a different uh setting
and it's really unclear to me how it's
possible to um
kind of cite suleiman
word for word
in dutch mainly because we also don't
know what language they were speaking in
at the council meeting so i'm not sure
that it's a translation and also just
substantively it didn't make sense in
the context that they were
they were in
that the company was asking to reduce
the number of clothes and yet suleiman's
retort suggests that
you know he was being asked to deal with
more clothes
um and so
that's certainly in question and i hope
it was clear that like i also think i
have my doubts about about this but the
important thing is that
for the administrators who are working
within this in this um system
it didn't really matter whether they
thought it was true or not they could
provide
evidence
by sending somebody
as witness
to the
event um to batavia and testify
in person
um and of course there you know the
clerks and administrators were so
incredibly meticulous to a point where
you know as i'm tracing his words and
multiple documents across the century
you know
there is no misspelling or changing of
the actual quote i mean they're
incredibly meticulous and writing it
down in the same way
um it's just that the interpret as if
it's kind of frozen in time right and
then the interpretations
around the quote changes over time
um
i
yeah i mean they're citing
local
local indigenous people all the time
this is not something that's unique
um
[Music]
so i'm not i
i don't
i don't really think that they were
being recited as kind of an
authentic indigenous voice
but more as evidence for different
arguments
at the time that they were writing so of
course in 1709 as van horn is
you know citing suleiman he's using it
to argue
um that the company had somehow tainted
you know
local people's character
and then you know and it doesn't have
much to do with authenticity
but that here is this evidence that this
ambonese person had changed he is not
compliant
right
um
and of course by 1775
they're
citing him again not to say that the
company administrators tainted
this man's character but out of fear
that people are not going to be happy
with um
you know just as fixed price
um based on bundled calculations from uh
the cost and the cost of clothes in the
previous five years
so
it's kind of an evidence for
how they think
the indigenous people will react to
certain policies
um
but i don't think it's just about this
kind of unique authentic indigenous
voice
thank you we have a question from al
lynn
hi thank you so much for your
presentation um i'm not a historian but
i'm just curious about kind of the power
relations and coming a bit more from
like an anthropological side
uh specifically with batavia and the
kind of relationship on the colonial
relationship so you're talking about the
governor who wrote a letter to batavia
i'm wondering kind of if you can speak a
little more who is on the receiving end
and thinking about how they and and in
the talk um write up you talked about
how there was a need to resolve their
present dilemmas for what they believed
to be a better future in this kind of
paper chain so i'm wondering who is the
one kind of shaping this future what
future did they kind of imagine um and
and and and kind of like who is the one
kind of deciding that they need to trans
uh convert this natural history
knowledge into an economically valuable
one um and kind of like who is on the
other side basically um thank you
yeah so there's thank you so much for
that question there's
kind of a clear hierarchy within the
company
and of course administrators stationed
in batavia are much more
powerful than administrators stationed
in these other port cities like ambon
ambon actually becomes this weird
training ground
for
um
you know
to get a position as a high-ranking
administrator in batavia
um
but of course within the kind of
european company sphere
the clerks the marginalists
and the archivists are also
not i mean they're kind of low
in the hierarchy we don't really hear
their voices all we have are their
signatures
but they were part of the system
of
using the archive to basically
collect information from the past for
forming present resolutions and of
course
much of this is going on in batavia but
this paper chain moves all the way from
outer provinces like in
outer provinces in ambon to batavia and
from batavia to amsterdam
so ultimately all of these reports are
being written
for the governor general in
in batavia but also those in amsterdam
who are much more powerful than anyone
stationed in these poor cities
um
[Music]
and of course like the people who
you know
are
the least just have no power within this
process um i would say are kind of
people like awesome suleiman right whose
voices
we think we hear but
were
left in doubt as to whether um
that was actually what he said whether
you know he's being interpreted in the
right way
um and of course you know
even when i talk about the knowledge of
um slaves from banda
um
it's not as if we have
uh
you know um
their their voices in this it's it's
much more about really collecting
information
right rather than
um
rather than kind of uh
in any way trying to
revive uh
like their agency within these documents
and i'm a bit wary of of doing that
mainly because it's kind of like who am
i to
who am i to do it but also um
it's interesting to see that
um
by looking at the paper chains one
realizes that i mean
i think i could have
written this
chapter in this paper just solely
focusing on assam suleiman about whom i
have a little more information which i
didn't present today
but ultimately
it became a case of
how the structure which i've outlined
here of of information being recycled in
the archive
completely overpowering any kind of
voice i can trace which i've i've tried
really hard to do
so thank you for your question on power
it's um it's it's everywhere
um and also kind of nowhere
so
thank you
i'm gonna
i don't see any other question but i'm
going to ask one last question um it's
kind of a theoretical question um but
you you mentioned the word agency in in
the documents
and you know you're a little wary about
and i was
pleasantly surprised in your talk how
you didn't go down the pathway
that's almost predictable nowadays when
people talk about documents as in the
agency of the non-human of the document
and all of these kinds of things which
which is interesting theoretically in
many ways
but sometimes it
departs from
the actual material so much that you
kind of lose the story a little bit but
it does raise a question for me i'm
curious like what you think about
the kind of
literature and things going on about the
agency of documents and all that you
certainly you must be thinking about
some of that a little bit as you write
but you have a unique approach to it it
seems i wonder if you could articulate
the way you think about those things
yeah
no thank you so much for this question
it's it is something i'm considering
but ultimately i think my whole project
is kind of based on
the power of reading and the power of
reading and interpreting
and changing value in the information
that people have
collected and read in the past
um which kind of goes into
you know
my writing about mediation
that
you know
[Music]
these documents don't i
i think that
it's really the people who are kind of
behind the documents who have the most
agency and yet are not exactly talked
about and
particularly in the context of the voc
um
so
you know it's
yeah i
i haven't really
mentioned the agency of archival
documents so much as the agency of the
clerks and the archivists who are
actively
compiling information and organizing
that information
and of course along the way the
transformation
that happens as they reinterpret or
selectively extract
shorter passages from longer resolutions
there
there are decisions being made that i
don't think that historians have fully
considered when they read their
historical documents
for example
the
the first part of my presentation
um
you know
the documents have the date of the
extracts which would be from like 1703
to 1715
but they don't have the date for when
those extracts were collected
one would have to
figure out the names of the clerks and
then trace the names of the clerks in
the voc
little name books in order to figure out
when they were extracted and for what
purposes
um
and so i think that's a good case of
showing that like
a lot of these uh documents have been
mediated over a very long period of time
and even within a very short period of
time if i talk about room fies all of
those documents have been mediated in
certain ways whether it's changing
indigenous knowledge or
using a scribe
to
dictating and using a scribe to document
certain information
copies of copies of copies
many of which are very different
and so um
i'm not sure that the object has as much
um
power as
uh i would like to imbue them i think
it's really the people who are kind of
invisible or have not been talked about
were
um
who are much more powerful and i i try
to be honest about that yeah
it's interesting i was thinking a little
bit about the system itself
having a kind of compulsion to it as
well though
for example when you mention that very
important shift from listing by date
and discovering that that conceals
things or something and then
desire to change it to an alphabetical
system right but once you shift to an
alphabetical system you have to fill in
a through z right
and eventually that itself generates a
certain kind of
process
say you finished a well then you're not
done you know you have to do b
and um it creates a kind of like
compulsion within itself that is quite
interesting
but the initial process is started by a
desire to shift right so it's quite
interesting
yeah it's kind of
i found it really interesting that they
didn't have the system in the 17th
century
that it's something that started very
much
in the 18th century the shift from well
it's not a complete shift because these
resolutions are still being written by
date
it's just that now they have this
massive index to
be able to organize that
information um
[Music]
but
yeah it's certainly um
kind of the way of thinking and there
isn't just one index this is kind of a
a process
um
that you know spans most of the 18th
century so there are multiple registers
which are then later compiled and
printed in in the 19th
and the 20th century so um
[Music]
and you know in the 19th century print
edition
they will say oh this is for
students who might be curious about
the history of the voc so students can
actually use the index
to search for i guess thesis topics or
something
and just to see if there are enough
documents about that one topic so it is
definitely kind of a major shift
in thinking about how to research
the vocs past
i think if we there's no further
questions i'm going to bring the talk to
a close um so i'll stop the recording
now and i'll leave the window open for a
few more minutes for informal
conversation after that but please
everyone join me in uh thanking eugenie
you for such a fascinating talk and
wonderful q a so thank you